it's been just over a week since apple's
m2 macbook pro has been out in the wild
and so far we've found seven problems
with it after one week some that aren't
as big of a deal and some that have
literally caused people to cancel their
orders which might actually be the right
move here because man apple kind of
messed up on the ssd situation but
before i get into that huge problem let
me first start off with some of the
other ones that we've noticed over the
past week the first problem is that the
m2 macbook pro uses exactly the same
design with absolutely no changes even
keeping the same touch bar which a lot
of people did not like including myself
meanwhile the macbook air gets a full
redesign with so many updates and
changes a beautiful display that's a
little bit larger with slimmer bezels
and basically an awesome new design but
with this one apple even reused old m1
macbook pro boxes and literally put a
new m2 sticker over the old one and
that's definitely not what apple is
known for doing this kind of shows that
apple doesn't really care about this
product or at least not enough to make
some new boxes with an updated wallpaper
to make people feel like it's a new
product now for problem number two
nothing else was upgraded in terms of
the actual feature set we have the same
exact speakers no changes same keyboard
same trackpad basically everything's the
same the display is the same no changes
at all it even has the same 720p webcam
while the less expensive m2 macbook air
is getting the 1080p webcam that is a
huge disappointment not only that but
this macbook is the only one that now is
not getting magsafe 3 for convenient and
fast charging now problem number three
has to do with apple's marketing which
is a bit overboard with this m2 macbook
pro first of all apple showed off that
the m2 chip supports 8k h.264 and hevc
encoders and decoders so this got me
very excited thinking that this m2
macbook pro is gonna be the best bang
for the buck video editing laptop out
there because it's equipped with the fan
and it has the m2 chip with 8k encoders
across the board however when we tested
a 5 minute 4k hevc export which is very
common it was only 5 seconds faster than
the m1 pro chip which has basically the
same encoders as the m1 now that is
hugely disappointing because apple never
marketed the m1 pro encoders as
supporting 8k but they did for the m2
and apparently 8k means 5 seconds faster
now it is nice that apple put in the pro
res media engine because it actually
does help quite a lot but the whole 8k
h.264 and hevc media engine part was way
overdoing it compared to the five second
difference that we actually experienced
now yes there might be some updates
coming but apple should honestly be
shipping the correct software updates
right away while launching new products
you shouldn't have to wait until mac os
ventura comes out or future updates to
use the machine at its full potential
and now moving on to problem number four
we have thermal throttling and there is
a lot to unpack here but i'm gonna start
with how much power the m2 chip uses in
the cinebench r23 stress test the m2
chip's cpu used 36 more power to get 13
more multi-core performance which is
definitely disappointing because it
shows that apple really had to boost the
clock speeds to squeeze out that extra
performance improvement and the issue
with overclocking the performance cores
that much is that it causes instability
which we noticed in our logic pro music
production stress test where the whole
point is to run as many tracks as
possible without overloading the chat
and the crazy thing is that the previous
m1 macbook pro was able to run 81 tracks
without overloading while the new m2
chip overloaded while running only 76
tracks which points to instability
within the chip and to prove that
stability is what matters for the logic
pro stress test intel's xeon chips
always performed much better in this
test compared to the regular core i9
cpus that were actually faster in terms
of raw cpu performance so stability
matters for this test but that's not the
end of the story because we experienced
severe thermal throttling on this m2
macbook pro more so than any macbook
we've ever used before what we did was
run an extreme stress test which is
exporting canon 8k raw from the canon r5
to 4k hevc now i will admit that this is
an extreme test that isn't meant for the
target market of the m2 macbook pro but
i specifically wanted to max out the cpu
and gpu as much as possible to stress
out the cooling system as much as
possible and honestly the truth is that
a computer's cooling system especially
one that's fully sealed like this empty
macbook pro and not upgradable should be
able to properly cool down the chip
that's inside of it without severely
thermal throttling because if it can't
that extra performance is being wasted
and the thing is that we ran this exact
extreme stress test on the previous m1
macbook pro and the gpu was stuck at 100
load the entire time without throttling
while requiring the fan to be basically
maxed out and then on the 14-inch
macbook pro it also adequately cooled
down the m1 pro chip without even maxing
out the fans but watch what happens to
the m2 macbook pro during the export
test the fan was stuck at maximum 7 200
rpms basically the entire time hitting
as much as 108 degrees celsius multiple
times which is higher than we've seen
even on intel max and since the fan was
already maxed out the system had no
choice but to drastically cut back on
the clock speeds with the performance
course going from 3200 megahertz to 1894
the efficiency core is going from 22 28
megahertz to 1444 and the gpu from 1393
to
289 megahertz all within a split second
which caused the temps to drop from 108
degrees to around 84 degrees celsius
before restarting the cycle over and
over again and the craziest thing was
that the m2 macbook pro cut the power to
the m2 chip from around 29.5 watts all
the way down to 7.3 watts which is the
most severe thermal throttling i've ever
seen on any macbook including intel
macbooks and when it finally finished
the test it was drastically slower than
the m1 pro macbook pro and it was only
10 faster than the previous m1 model
even though that model was gpu limited
the entire time which is disappointing
because without thermal throttling the
m2 cpu is 18 faster and the gpu is 35
faster so we should expect better
performance in this test and not only
just 10 and now moving on to problem
number five we have the ssd issue which
has basically blown up all over the
internet with the base model m2 macbook
pro with 256 gigs of ssd apple chose to
only fill one of the ssd spots on the
logic board compared to the previous m1
macbook pro which had both of the spots
filled and this is basically causing the
transfer speeds to be drastically
reduced as much as two times slower for
the read speed compared to the previous
m1 macbook pro and the crappy thing
about that is that it's gonna slow down
your large file transfers it could
potentially slow down the opening and
loading of apps and games compared to
the previous m1 macbook pro but what
really blew our mind was that this ssd
is slower than apple's ipad air 5 with
only a 64 gigabyte ssd and that ipad
starts at just six hundred dollars
instead of thirteen hundred dollars for
the m2 macbook pro and now for problem
number six not only did apple switch to
one nand ship instead of two on the base
model which instantly cuts away half of
the channels but the actual nand chips
themselves are worse quality than on
previous macbooks and to prove this we
actually tested the 512 gig ssd model of
the m2 macbook pro so what we did is
compare the m2 macbook pro to our
previous 16-inch intel 2019 macbook pro
model that seems like it has slower ssd
write speeds than the 512 gig ssd in the
m2 macbook pro according to the
blackmagic disc test and we did a large
file transfer and we found that it
finished faster on the old intel model
compared to this new m2 macbook pro with
a 512 gigabyte ssd and how is that
possible well it seems like apple is
starting to use lower quality ssds that
slow down more after a certain amount of
data is transferred specifically when
the intel 16 inches ssd slowed down it
continued to transfer at about 900
megabytes per second which is pretty
good but on the m2 macbook pro's 512 gig
ssd once it slowed down it went all the
way down to an average of around 350
megabytes per second which caused it to
transfer the file slower basically
almost a minute slower so what this
essentially means is that apple
downgraded the quality of these new nand
ssd chips compared to the previous ones
which means that apple is trying to save
money so we did a bit of research online
and we found that a
gig flash nand wafer costs apparently
only two dollars and four cents on the
chinese market which was updated today
as i'm filming this so this shows that
apple is trying to squeeze every ounce
of profit margin out of this m2 macbook
pro in order to keep the base price at
the same 1299 while upgrading it with
the m2 chip so from what it seems like
the supply chain and inflationary issues
are probably worse than we think with
apple making such a weird change going
from two chips to one on the base model
ruining the performance and in my
opinion apple made a huge mistake and
misjudgment by choosing to cut costs on
this specific part of the macbook pro
particularly because of the seventh and
final problem for this video the slow
256 gig base ssd is negatively impacting
the performance of the virtual memory
swap because when the very low eight
gigs of ram which honestly shouldn't
even be an option on the mt macbook pro
when that fills up it has to resort to
the ssd to use as virtual memory and the
slower the ssd is the slower that
virtual memory is as well which slows
down performance so we ended up testing
this by opening 10 chrome tabs in the
background and then running a couple of
real world tests and multiple times the
m2 macbook pro ended up being slower
than the previous m1 macbook pro this
should never happen the new model
performing worse than the old model this
is embarrassing and it's a huge fail by
apple for choosing to go with just that
one nand chip so with that said i can
safely say that apple messed up badly
with the m2 macbook pro and the worrying
part about all of this is that there's a
good chance that the m2 macbook air also
comes with the slow ssd issue as well as
likely suffering even more from thermal
throttling issues not only in extreme
tests like the one that we ran but
probably even in more of the common
tests as well so honestly i've got to
say that i'm a bit disappointed with the
m2 macbook pro so there you guys go
those were the top seven problems with
the m2 macbook pro and if you disagree
with any of them let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video and it was insightful to you
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe because we have a lot more
testing to go especially the m2 macbook
air and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video